a book fair in a city where words
now have consequences it's being held in
the shadow of a recently imposed law
that critics say has narrowed the space
for free speech here
it's an annual event but covet 19 forced
its cancellation a year ago
now though hong kong's physical and
political health
is returning says its leader oh gohan
i am happy that this year's book fair
can be held again since the
epidemic is contained the organizers
insist
books have not been vetted or censored
but exhibitors know they must be careful
about what they promote and say all our
books are focused on the
language learning history and art
we are not worried about it do you have
any books here about recent
political events in hong kong this is
not our publishing
term so we don't have this kind of
publish johnny lau has just written a
book
about the relationship between china's
communist party
and hong kong but no publisher will
touch it
the first time that's happened to him
since the handover from britain
24 years ago well i think it is
completely
different the political
content
almost disappeared well in the book fair
this year and all the
books talking about politics
share the points of views of the
government
one author however ticks all the right
boxes here
a three volume collection of speeches
and writings by
china's president xi jinping on
prominent display
the self-censorship is evident the
titles on display here
are safe and that is a further reminder
of the fact that hong kong
is increasingly walking in political
lockstep
with the mainland exhibitors may be wary
of breaking the law
but that caution has not dampened public
interest
with long queues outside the venue
i can get the books i want here and also
outside
i've just come here to have a look we
did find one book perhaps
that fell into the politically risky
category
the authors currently in jail awaiting
trial
accused of violating national security
otherwise
little else to reflect the momentous
events of the past few years
that history it seems is slowly being
erased
adrian brown al jazeera hong kong